[Music]
foreign
a first look at what is on the front
pages as they arrive in the next half
hour then we'll see what's making the
headlines with the columnist and
broadcaster Steve Richards and the
former conservative special advisor
Salma Shah great to see both of you so
as ever let's kick off with the front
pages the nurses pay dispute leads the
eye with a warning from hospital bosses
that the stalemate needs to be broken
because the backlog in the care system
is so serious the express quotes one NHS
leader criticizing nurses who refuse to
staff a struggling intensive care Ward
despite management please the guardian
returns to the channel migrants crisis
and says the home office is to acquire a
fleet of ships to house Asylum Seekers
coming to the UK before they are
processed the collapse of another U.S
Bank this time First Republic and its
takeover by JP Morgan is top story for
the financial times
Crown the hatch the Metro begins The
Final Countdown to the coronation with
news that
652 million pints of beer will be drunk
in celebration making 120 million pounds
profit for the country's pubs
The Daily Mail meal World carries a poll
which finds that support for the royal
family is Rock Solid but that the
institution does need some reform look
who's pictured too and the Daily Star
says to David Attenborough is the
nation's favorite to lead any talks with
beings from another planet should they
ever get in touch
let's hope they don't anyway a reminder
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us so let's head
straight to Our Guest then Steve
Richards and Salma Shaw and Salma you
kick off with the eye then making the
case of the impact of the strikes that
we've seen with nurses today more than
500 000 appointments and procedures
already hit by strikes with a waiting
list now of 7.2 million patients
suggesting Hospital bosses are desperate
yes and this is an interesting story and
an interesting take from the eye because
there's been generally quite a lot of
support for striking NHS workers but the
management at these hospitals in these
institutions are now obviously making a
statement about how difficult it's going
to be to manage this we've already had
uh the backlog from the pandemic and now
this is bringing more stress to acute
services in fact the president of the
Royal Society of acute treatment has
called this an eternal winter so there
are some really Stark language being
used there and I think it is because
we're having this discussion about uh
pay tomorrow and whether the NHS workers
nurses in particular are going to accept
a five percent pay deal uh this has been
something that is a little bit of a push
I think to get people uh moving and back
into the hospitals yes it's interesting
isn't it because the RCN leader today
said let's not just talk about Staffing
or acute Staffing shortages on strike
days that's an everyday occurrence in
the NH chess but meanwhile if we head to
the Metro or the inside page is the
Metro Steve this idea of a big meeting
tomorrow and that there could be an
imposition of the pay award
um does that also Focus Minds do you
think tell us about that
well it's the later stage in this
extraordinary dispute I mean nurses
don't normally go on strike remember the
context of this is that they have
rejected a paid proposal that was
actually backed by their leadership the
union leadership so
um some of them I think uh are pretty
desperate because of all kinds of things
it's not just the inflation rate it's
the cost of housing in parts of Britain
there are a whole series cost of
Transport
um the whole series of things that
frankly aren't working very well in this
country that have led to this um
position but the wider context is urgent
to Salma suggests you know in analyzing
other front pages I mean we had the uh
Coalition policy from 2010 a very tight
NHS budgets we've then had the pandemic
um and you know we've had staff
shortages for years now and remember one
of sunax kind of five missions or
pledges or however they're described is
to address the waiting lists and up they
go so there's a real urgency around
these uh talks tomorrow
um on on both uh sides of the uh
metaphorical table yes and on Tuesday it
will be Health unions a number of Health
unions ministers and NHS buses
discussing that payoff of five percent
the health secretary Salma already
suggesting that the Royal College of
nursing's decision to press ahead with
its strike was disrespectful to the
other unions involved and they of course
hit their six-month mandate deadline as
we know because of Court action uh
having to call it off um a day earlier
um but what will happen do you think on
Tuesday will we see a majority vote for
the current pay offer and if so what
does that mean for unions who are
seeking a further mandate from their
members to strike more
well this is interesting because there
is a lot of negotiation that happens
behind the scenes uh in these
circumstances and instances and I think
that is going to be really working
through rapidly this evening as to what
the positions are going to be around uh
the distinct unions and their
interactions with each other but I think
ultimately you can take it to a point
where
um you know there's all these headlines
and a lot of pressure coming from lots
of different places and still not get a
deal because people are really
entrenching into their positions and
you're seeing a heightened language both
from the Secretary of State and the
nursing unions so it doesn't feel like
this is going to be the opening for a
majority vote however you know never say
never there there could be a lot of
people who want to get back to work I
mean we are talking about the care
sector and people who want to help their
patients so there could be a break as
far as the membership is concerned but
the way that the leadership on both
sides are talking it doesn't look like
the impasses it's going to is is going
to occur
lots of coverage about this let's take a
look at the express as well it picks up
on an NHS bosses or sorry NHS unions
ignoring a plea for life for limb care
um this happened at Colchester hospital
we understand it involved in intensive
care unit life and limb care had been
promised had it not but it just shows
how fractious it's getting just briefly
Steve doesn't it
yeah and how difficult it is sometimes
to Define these terms absolutely clearly
so those on you know strike can provide
the cover they say they will and and so
on this is what happens when industrial
action uh deepens for whatever reason
um and this is deepening and I think for
example the RCN leadership or in
something of a dilemma they can't
recommend an agreement to their members
and get it rejected again so they have
to be really sure and that's one of the
many calculations uh that are being made
tonight and will no doubt uh seep
through in these discussions tomorrow
but the ministers need these nurses back
and say it's one of sunak's pledges uh
and and actually what's happening is
that the waiting lists are growing and
certainly cultures to hospitals
suggesting that they had to
significantly reduce their capacity in
the Intensive Care Unit meaning only one
patient could be admitted on Sunday
night so great difficulty for for many
different parts of various hospitals
because of the strike action uh we'll
see what happens obviously on Tuesday
let's move on to the guardian now back
to migration and Asylum Seekers
the political editor with what she says
is an exclusive here Sama that the home
office is to get up to 10 disused cruise
liners ferries and barges to tackle
processing delays so talk us through
this
yes so it's this idea that obviously
with the influx of uh migration and
particularly the acute issue of small
boats coming across the channel that the
home office is now scrambling to find
accommodation for migrants and this is
going to be a huge list all the way from
disused um prisons to military sites and
the ships which of course is going to
create a lot of consternation lots of
refugee charities in particular will
have issue with this but it does speak
to the fact that the prime minister's
original Pledge over in January back in
January was about dealing with the small
boats and by extension immigration
issues now they can't get lots of Tory
MPS or indeed many MPS to want to accept
people into their communities so they
are looking for other options and the
boats seem to be
um one part of what they might do to
house migrants that are coming in
yes the suggestion is that the next
place will be Liverpool hopefully after
they've hosted the Eurovision song
contest Steve but anyway uh next in line
um it comes as ministers
um confirmed plans to house about 400
migrants on a barge in Dorset uh trying
to allay concerns from Tory back benches
over the use of hotels in their
constituencies and the suggestion is
that these 10 vessels at a cost of
millions of pounds to the taxpayer I
mean they're floundering around aren't
they because the backlog is so enormous
yeah this is getting sort of Darkly
silly I think the last time we were off
they announced uh one particular boat uh
and the MPS in the area where the boat
was going to be moored uh was against
the boat being moored in their area and
on it goes I mean I in one of the papers
they're going to use oil rigs and then
what else castles you know the the
problems are so deep and in a way this
issue of supplies I mean what's going to
happen you know you the sky did quite a
lot today have been leading with Sudan
uh that's going to lead if people can
get out of people are desperate to get
out to people from Sudan coming over
here and so on so there's a much deeper
issue about what you do about people
moving away from areas of Crisis and
emergency and in a way this kind of
doing putting them in boats putting on
oil rigs and all the rest of it
um to the point where every boat in
Britain will be up occupied
um is is just not really getting to the
the nub of this now maybe it will help
speed up processes who knows but you get
a hint of kind of desperation in all of
this because there has been this again a
sooner pledge to sort out the boats yes
and the guardian suggesting that
Whitehall sources said Suella bravman
was close to confirming a deal for an
1800 capacity former cruise ship to
house migrants that would be birthed in
the mersey
um suggesting that uh the port
infrastructure around birkenhead would
go ahead only if the plans had full
engagement with the local Council so we
watch and see with that one as well but
some big plans there
um now we've talked about strike action
here peaceful picket lines not so much
in France though where people are still
smarting at the pushing through of
pension reforms by President macro
salmer and effectively we're being told
by correspondent the loss of democracy
is what is so agitated people there
yes and this is this is something that
was sort of predicted when President
macron suggested pension reforms you
know it bits from um that we've already
sort of Taken on in terms of increasing
the retirement age and even though we're
talking about strikes in this country
and it being difficult this is nothing
compared to what's happening in Paris at
the moment where right police are on the
street and you can see the pictures
there
um and uh and the fact that this doesn't
seem to show any sign of resolution at
any point soon
um people are very angry about the way
that president macron has brought in
these changes seemingly without enough
consultation uh with workers and
certainly uh their May Day holiday which
most people enjoy has turned into it's a
bit of Carnage really on the streets of
Paris today